wir kommen jetzt zum höhepunkt dieses
videos das ist wirklich ein schuh das
soll den jungs schon sein aber ich habe
ihn zum glück noch nie irgendwo auf der
straße gesehen
hey was geht ab jetzt bekommen weil mein
video endlich mal wieder hier ich glaube
ich habe jetzt schon wieder irgendwie
fünf tage oder so nichts rauskommen
würden wir auch mega leid aber ich habe
heute meine erste abi prüfung
geschrieben war durch spar eigentlich
ganz okay ich denke mal so ne 3 wird es
bestimmt nicht dafür nicht ist auch egal
ich mache youtube mensch passt auf jeden
fall habe ich gerade einfach dieses t
shirt form wiedergefunden das habe ich
irgendwie verloren von ja ich hab das
mal richtig gefeiert und jetzt habe ich
einfach wieder geil oder noch gar nicht
angekommen jemand zum thema ich habe
letztens irgendwann oder schon alles
schon so zwei monate her da habe ich es
wieder gemacht die geilsten schule für
mädchen das wirklich ganz gut abbildung
hat glaube ich über 25.000 unbedingt
dazu ist am morgen oder video
beschreibung wenn ich gesehen hab hier
nachschauen aber heute geht es um die
geilsten und hässlichsten schuhe für
jungs da habe ich wirklich von euch
einfach ins heim gesteckt bekommen da
habe ich das ding 14 ist für schurig
will gar nicht glauben ich habe hier
alle auf dem pc gucken wir jetzt
zusammen mit euch an und dann werden wir
ein bisschen ablästern bzw
abgesagt man dass keine ahnung wenn es
euch gefällt angelaufen teil sehen wollt
könnt ihr jetzt schon mal doch nach
unterlassener macht das bestimmt noch
mal für mädchen ihr könnt mir schuhe
immer schick so bilder von schon fenster
oder so installiert kurz eingeblendet
ja und ich würde sagen wir fangen an
let's go letzter athlet beginnen ich
nehme jetzt einfach irgendein ist das
ein schuh also auf der einen seite finde
ich den gar nicht so
dort ist so hässlich was ist das das ist
ein michael jordan 2 irgendwas keine art
ich weiß die namen von den schuhen
natürlich nicht allerdings ist der schuh
dass sie irgendwie mehr so aus wie so
ein boot so als könnte er weiß ich
stelle mir gerade vor ich habe davon
zwei an und kann einfach so über das
wasser fahren
also wurde farben habe ich eigentlich
ziemlich geil allerdings weiß ich nicht
ich würde ich mir nicht kaufen wir
machen weiter mit dem nächsten schule
und wahrnehmen nur einfach mal
wir nehmen ich glaub ich hab ich schon
mal gesehen als ich das gestern
durchgang das ist dieser schuh ich finde
ich so geil ich weiß aber nicht wie
heißt dieser für wie heißt er wendet
wenn ihr das vielleicht ein mädchen
jetzt könnte ich mich ein bisschen
blamieren allerdings finde ich den schuh
echt geil selbst wenn es ein mädchen
schubert
ich würde mir den kaufen weil es doch
scheißegal wenn ich den tragen jungs
schuh ich weiß echt nicht wieder reißt
ich finde dann könnt ihr ein bisschen
dunkelheit aber wenn ihr wisst wieder
heißt was das finale hat dieser schule
helfers für deutsch wenn ihr mir bitte
sagen haben verraten ich würde gerne
kaufen ohne scheiß den hole ich mir als
nächstes okay leute wir machen weiter
mit dem nächsten schule ich nehme
einfach mal hier sollen rosen da habe
ich mir würde es der jury und weiß ich
will auch keinen von euch zu nahe treten
wenn ihr vielleicht diesen schuh habt
aber ich habe noch nie so einen
hässlichen schuhe gesehen was ist das
denn bitte keine ahnung was da an
hässlich ist aber irgendwie es alles
hässlich also das gesamte package auf
die farbe ist hässlich auch mal diese
leute die rote schuhe tragen ich hab
selber mutter auch immer diese leute die
blaue schuhe haben keine ahnung ich weiß
auch nicht wieder als wenn ihr es wisst
ihr könnt gerne in die kommentare
schreiben
hässlich oder okay leute kommt zu einem
schuh da wusste ich nicht ob ich denn
jetzt richtig geil finden soll
oder richtig scheiße also und zwar als
aus dieser ja ich bin so legen wir auf
der einen seite so ist er voll geil also
dass das richtige peter studer nicht den
kann man so 2025 tragen aber jetzt schon
haben
versteht ihr also das meine ich so wenn
ihr den schuh jetzt schon habt dann seid
ihr den leuten im jahr 2025 einfach so
neun jahre voraus ich weiß auch an von
welcher marke der ist wenn die swiss
trips in die kommentare schreibt den
ganzen namen in die kommentare
ja finde ich eigentlich ich würde mir
den sogar kaufen und gucken wieder so
passt zu meinen hosen oder so vielleicht
kann er ja auch schon fliegen sieht ein
bisschen so aus ich weiß es nicht wir
kommen jetzt zum höhepunkt dieses videos
das ist wirklich ein schuh das soll den
jungen schul sein aber ich habe ihn zum
glück noch nie irgendwo auf der straße
gesehen muss ich auch gar nicht aber ich
könnte mir vorstellen so was du alles in
die trends kommt jetzt gibt's ja auch
irgendwie mails oder so das können wir
jetzt auch wieder anscheinend es gibt
zumindest viele online shops die menge
ins verkaufen ich habe mir auch meine
bestellt habe ich euch ja versprochen
das video kommt am donnerstag
nein ich trage keine megans eigentlich
ist auch egal ich könnte mir gut
vorstellen dass dieser schuh bald
richtig im trend ist und zwar hat er
einfach ein schwarz denn einfach schwanz
oder egal ich hoffe schwarz ich glaube
wenn ich mit sommerschuh zu meinen
großeltern gehen würde die würden sagen
gut dass wir früher jung war
wie kommt man auf die idee einen schuh
den schwanz zu verpassen ich meine da
fehlt doch auch dreckig das wird sich so
ein bisschen zwei mädchen ist das nicht
anders bestimmt gedacht kommen wir
machen jetzt mal vom aussehen her denn
richtig hässlichen schuh mit einem
richtig hässlich im farbton den wir dann
auf den richtig hässlichen schwanz
verpassen
leute das war jetzt mal wieder fünf oder
sechs keine ahnung richtig geile
beziehungsweise hässliche schreibt meine
kommentare welcher von denen hat euch am
besten gefallen würde mich echt mal
interessieren ansonsten könnt ihr gerne
nach oben da lassen wenn ihr das wieder
für mich ich ihn sehen wollt also die
geilsten schuhe und hässlichen show für
mädchen schickt mir nie einfach über
insta direkt auskommt anwalt und
ansonsten wünsche einen schönen tag aber
nicht vergessen hier oben links geht so
weiter mit meinem video ins remstal als
eingewendet sektors hob ab und dann
sehen wir uns am nächsten donnerstag
wieder da kommt dann das video zu dieser
megans hobby wenn die burgen ankommt
aber müsste sie eigentlich und die
oberbayerin chem